[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it is i brian
keating your fearful host in these times
of
emerging from pandemic podcasting and
into a
very very uh exciting interview for me
which is uh meeting one of my favorite
authors one of my inspirations and
thankfully i was trying to get him on
the show as i was saying
for years and and it was only until he
wrote a book this wonderful book called
bewilderment uh then i was able to tie
in a little bit of my professional
courtesy perhaps too
to someone who writes a book uh that is
a novel that is heart-wrenching that is
beautifully written
and
evocative of so many things that we talk
about on this channel including
astrobiology the search for life on
other planets uh there's a
a very very strong theme throughout here
of the environment of taking care of our
planet while we do search for other
planets and other creatures we also find
in this magical book a discussion of
some of the upcoming preview perhaps of
mind computer interface that we'll talk
about with when we discuss consciousness
and that's uh today's guest is richard
powers author of bewilderment you may
know him from the overstory and it's
just such a delight he's a
professor now he's up at stanford the
knight professor and uh and he uh he is
joining us all the way from northern
california i wish we could be in person
but i have a little bit of a cold but i
wouldn't miss this interview for the
world so richard thank you so much for
coming on the podcast thank you so much
brian and thanks for the generous intro
i have to make just one small correction
okay uh i did leave stanford a few years
ago oh sorry uh and i've been uh working
full-time as a as a novelist since then
uh living in the smokies which we can
talk about it has a bearing on the book
but i happen to be back in northern
california at the moment on an extended
book tour for bewilderment so yeah back
in my old stomping grounds but for
different reasons right now well any
excuse that brings you closer to us we
will take uh so richard as i explained
every uh every author that that graces
me and my audience uh with their with
their uh guest appearance i always ask
the the same question that you're never
supposed to ask but for people that
aren't familiar what else do they have
to judge a book by besides its cover and
so i want to ask you about the title i
want to ask you about the the image on
the cover
and uh and this wonderful uh some of the
other
features we'll get into in just a bit on
the cover as well so can we now do the
famous segment judging books by their
covers how'd you come up with the title
and the cover design please
well
you know let's start with the image uh
that can be a very fraught process and
what's interesting about it you know
people don't always consider this but
for a book like bewilderment that gets
translated into
you know several different languages
that process happens again and again and
again in different cultures than in
different uh
language groups
and
there is
a lot of difference between what an
author would like to see on the cover
and what an editor would like to see on
the cover and what a policies like to
see on the cover you know we all have
our uh personal agendas
and you know they want some kind of
mystical resonance with things in the
story
uh the the you know the editor wants
some kind of professionally identifiable
set of semiotics for positioning the
book in a bookstore and of course the
publicist wants uh an image that will
connect to the broadest number of
possible readers there was a a good
uh presentation of cover possibilities
uh for the book uh after i submitted my
final draft and i actually blocked up
several of myself in my own amateurish
photoshopping way
with an eye toward suggesting the scope
of the book the book concerns
uh
a widow in his late 30s theo byrne who
is an astrobiologist
at the uh university of wisconsin
madison and his nine-year-old special
unusual son robin
whose mother has died about two years
before the start of the book
and uh
theo robin is neurodivergent and is
experiencing increasing behavioral
difficulties in his school
theo is trying to get him adequately
diagnosed and get a proper response
to this boy who's
having more and more trouble coping with
his own anxiety including acute
ecotrauma
so the cover had to suggest those things
and it also you know i i really wanted
it to suggest
an
element
of science speculation in the book
that becomes very important both in
terms of subject and theme
one of the very few things that uh calm
robin down is when theo
in place of bedtime stories
takes robin on a journey across the
galaxy across the universe uh
visiting
uh
examples of the kinds of exoplanets that
have been turned up by planet hunters in
recent years that have been considered
contemplated explored uh by his own
field of astrobiology
so i wanted a cover that suggested that
kind of
cosmic uh
subject matter that also invoked
uh the intimacy of the story it's told
entirely by theo in the first person as
a memoir of his uh
year
uh tragic and difficult year with his
challenging son i wanted to suggest that
father-son relationship the first covers
that we were looking at
also i think uh being nudged uh by
the the people at my uh pushing house
to suggest a much broader accessibility
a much simpler style a shorter more
straightforward book than i've written
in the past
they wanted to invoke a kind of
crossover book the covers that they were
suggesting had human figures on them
set
on a you know a sublime or a
spectacular earthly landscape with a big
big sky in the background but they had a
kind of young adult tint
or tinge to them that i was okay with
but i thought we could do better and
create a more
universal look
and i actually found the image that we
ended up using what was interesting is
the image was cropped very very
differently so that the horizon line the
aspect uh ratio of the of the picture
and also the figure there was only one
human figure the the the man uh the
figure
on the right as you look at the cover
yep and
uh through great uh
magic the design
folks at norton were able to add a
second figure of a boy they cropped the
sky they added this
light show this
comet or spectacular object meteor
perhaps moving across the low horizon
and all of a sudden it seemed to me that
we had a very elegant very simple design
now it's been interesting to watch the
book be taken up as i say by other
countries the uk had a very beautiful
image
almost like an arkham boldo a lush
image filled with earthly life that in a
kind of
visual pun
forms the profile of a young child and i
thought that was very beautiful too and
that's been taken up in other countries
but it's funny when you put them side by
side you do realize
uh although you're not supposed to judge
by a book by cover
you are being uh subtly psychically
influenced by the cover every time you
pick it up and get back into the story
yeah i love it i i always used to say
you know richard that
uh you know i never understood why books
have these jackets you know because what
do they call they're called dust jackets
and i and i was thinking like how much
dust is like flying around people's
shell you know
and then
funnily enough my book is all about
cosmic dust which makes an appearance in
this book also my book was published by
norton norton uh graciously introduced
us so it's it's wonderful uh to have
that uh connection and i want to get
into all the phenomenal science really
heavy duty research science you know i i
one of my favorite things to do is is
when my kids tell me that they found an
error you know in in one of my books or
typos which they have found
more than i care to admit uh but you
know at least the first book i had
professional editors and everybody
reading it right so i can't only be
blamed um but i couldn't find any
scientific you know gaffes or flaws or
anything like that in this book it's
really an impressive book and the
following up of course on the on the
previous you know smash success also in
kind of the naturalistic
genre and i want to get into in the
future if we have time you know what
what what comes next is there a trilogy
in this sort of you know uber theme of
nature the world the universe but we
haven't finished the cover yet because
there are some other things on the cover
that i want to get into first of all
there is winner of the pulitzer prize um
and i've had on 11 nobel prize winners
i've had on um you're the second
pulitzer prize winner i have the third
one coming up ed young who wrote i
contain multitudes coming on for his new
book in june so stay tuned please
subscribe to the channel but then
there's this thing there's a sticker
whoops uh oprah's book club
did you get to meet oprah as well as
what is the meaning of this
it's interesting i i was stunned uh i
was
uh in bed uh in my cabin in the the
forest of the smokies uh reading and uh
the phone rang and it's almost always a
telemarketer uh but this one had a 312
area called chicago area
you know my family comes from chicago i
still have family in chicago and i have
a lot of friends in chicago and i didn't
recognize number but i better answer
this you know the telemarketers tend to
come from the west coast uh so i picked
it up and and she said you know richard
powers this is oprah and my immediate
you know thought was
one very sadistic friend of mine is
doing a very good voice imitation but
you know that voice was too famous to to
imitate so perfectly
and it turns out uh
that
she
was a great fan of the over story but
that book at 500 plus pages
uh with very complex and and multiple
narrative styles unfolding over a large
period of time and on a fairly uh
esoteric subject uh didn't fit well with
her book club and so she was delighted
when bewilderment came out shorter more
accessible much more intimate you know
it can be read as a family drama as a
father-son duet
uh she was delighted that uh she finally
had a book of mine that fit better with
her club we did a a long interview she's
uh
extremely well read better read than i
am and uh
such a such a great interlocutor and has
such a an art uh in in extracting from
novels all the salient emotional and
thematic components and as she told me
you know after that interview she said
she does the club
out of the love of fiction
and makes no money on it and she just
does it because uh novelists are her
rock stars
so it was quite an experience
uh getting selected and getting a chance
to talk to her well maybe you can turn
that to some support for astrobiology we
we certainly could use it
for biology this book is is replete with
really very what i would call hard
science fiction i've had on andy weir
who is a graduate and i should say that
there's a lot of science fiction that
comes out of uc san diego and
particularly our arthur c clarke center
for human imagination and the clarion
writers workshop that we run we have
david brin as an alumnus we have kim
stanley robinson as an alumnus yeah we
have a lot of good hard science fiction
and this is very much in that in that
vein i mean i listened to it and read it
as well and the audiobook is just
delightfully narrated the narrator did
a very wonderful job of communicating
the tenderness the angst the anxiety
that we have as parents um and i want to
turn to that because as i understand
you're not a parent and i would like to
to kind of um you know again i'm just
over awed by the both the graciousness
that you treat the father-son
relationship the widower relationship
etc but uh but before we do i do want to
give some
red tofu to
to my astra my more more astronomically
inclined uh audience so this book
is is really um a tale of of other
worlds in some level in the inner space
and outer space this frequently comes up
so robbie is the special needs kid
neurodivergent perhaps autistic we don't
know there's so many different
definitions
and as i was saying before we started
recording you know richard the you know
when i was a kid i the first time i met
somebody that had a peanut allergy i was
30 years old like a lot of these things
come up and and especially these new
diagnosis which is the most common
diagnosis for kids but one of the things
the only things that can really soothe
him during his
episodes where he is kind of uh overcome
by this inner torment that he might be
suffering from is by his father's uh
bedtime stories and his father takes him
through journeys through the galaxy and
beyond and i wanted to you know
we often hear here at the arthur c
clarke center
um and the clarion writers workshop
about world building
and uh this book literally has more
worlds in it than any other book i've
ever read even andy weir's books
so i'm gonna ask yeah what what is the
inspiration for that i mean how do how i
mean i i always find it very uh
challenging when you talk to like a
comedian and you ever ever watch like
jimmy kimmel and he's talking to a
community what makes you so funny i
guarantee you the next things that comes
out are not funny like
very like but i don't want to ask you
like how do you do what you do but but
what was it about astronomy astrobiology
that appealed to you
well
gosh you know there's there's so much on
the table with uh with what you've just
uh said and asked and let me let me
start by by talking about
uh the way that my books have positioned
themselves
in the relationship between science and
and fiction over the years you're uh
considerably younger than i am as is
theo in the in the book
uh
but uh it the age is important in the
case of this
subject because astrobiology is a young
discipline and i wanted to create a
character who was old enough to see it
go from non-existent to fairly well
established in a short period of time
but before this book this is my 13th
novel
i have spent many of those uh
13 books
exploring the social
and personal consequences of lives spent
in science in in particular uh
scientific research
and i've explored the effects of those
sciences and the technologies that have
spun out of those sciences
on
what we call the human condition and
my books have not always been
science fiction in the hard sense of the
word
that is to say they haven't always
ventured into speculation they haven't
changed
uh the rules of our existence here they
haven't explored
uh distant futures they've dabbled with
what often
science fiction writers will explore
which is the near-term future uh just
that next horizon into the impossible
where the impossible and the uh possible
are just
uh starting to kind of uh
change uh their respective boundaries
but by and large i would say my fiction
has been
up until now
largely literary and fiction literary in
nature but using
scientific research
as
subject matter for literary fiction that
is you know literary fiction will do
this on occasion but often it's fairly
rudimentary it's fairly crude there's a
test tube bubbling away in the
background or somebody's got a white
coat on you know but i really uh
want to write these books uh as a way of
inhabiting
the mind and the world view of people
who are
who are in these pursuits
my friend and science studies author
bruno latour was trying to introduce the
word scientifician for a while
to distinguish between sf and
literary fiction that wants to use
science as its subject matter and its
theme i if word never really got
traction and you can kind of see why
it's not it's not an elegant word
but nevertheless i think it's a good
distinction
what i do what i've done in the last two
books i think is has turned a little bit
it's tried to open up
that
more realist more naturalist fiction
that i've been writing for you know
almost a dozen novels before these two
and introduce elements of speculation
introduce elements of spiritual
reflection and strangeness uh to expand
the ways in which the
the story uh is able to explore uh
the ramifications of a world
being profoundly changed by
the rapid advances of our knowledge and
our ability to manipulate uh
the physical and temporal worlds
so
astrobiology when i was an undergraduate
didn't exist at all in fact you know i
began my undergraduate career studying
physics
and
this uh did involve flirtations with
astronomy and cosmology uh and at the
time it really was taboo to say anything
at all about what life out there might
look like uh you know
there was almost a consensual agreement
that you know i mean there's there's
always that positive this prohibition
against talking about things that you
can't know
and at the time we couldn't because we
didn't have the tools to go out and even
see what that term in the drake equation
of how many planets per sun per star
there were right we had no idea you know
we had one case to reason from right so
it was all a bit you know it was all a
bit suspect you could if you were carl
sagan you could get away with a little
bit of
lyrical speculation um but by and large
i think the the the field uh correct me
if i'm wrong but the general feel was
the the field shied away from
uh any kind of uh
professional speculation yeah i think
that's right and i had on both uh carl's
daughter sasha sagan who's a wonderful
writer in her own right and uh and his
widow andruian as well who wrote the
novel contact with carl who's only known
as only fiction book and you're
absolutely right i asked her you know
what was his reaction because he was
almost shunned in some sense by the
scientific community famously being
denied entry into the national academies
of science uh some said because he had
too much of a personality and outward
facing and yet nowadays if you look
richard at the at the um case being made
for telescopes like the james webb which
there is a thinly veiled you know
reference to the james webb space
telescope was written of course
published before the web was launched
successfully and i want to get into your
hopes and aspirations for that project
but you see it now for these giant
telescopes some rivaling the cost of
webb telescope or the next generation
telescope that you talk about in your
book uh billions of dollars and their
primary capstone
key project is to look for
signals of life in the universe that
never would have been visible to someone
like sagan even 20 years ago
but you've seen yeah in in retrospect
that sagan's speculations and his
general attitude about what we're doing
and and how we might go about doing it
have been vindicated many times over
you know you have also had on
uh sarah seeker and you know who
uh you know has been
at the center of this search for
exoplanets
and it is absolutely mind-boggling what
has been put on the table in just a
matter of a few decades so we had the
galileo telescope in in 89
and uh followed
20 years later by kepler
and all of a sudden were not stuck in
this little reasoning from one case
anymore you know
uh and it's it's mind-blowing to think
of the foundational work i mean when you
think
of stellar dimming
and
wobble
and
planetary lensing you know gravitational
lensing as methods for determining what
i think many astronomers when i was uh
an undergraduate would have thought
would never be possible right it's
really a revolution yeah and it's time
for fiction to catch up with that
revolution and realize that our thinking
now about who we are
who the neighbors might be you know what
the what the potentials and uh
possibilities for life are all of those
questions have changed profoundly and so
they should change the stories that
we're telling about ourselves about life
here on planet earth yes absolutely and
we have you know kind of i see science
fiction as a way to kind of pre-game or
do what what einstein used to call
gdunkin experiments thought experiments
what could the future be like in our
namesake here at the arthur c clarke
center arthur c clarke famously
predicted things like telepresence and
satellites and and even things like
facetime and ipads and so forth but i
wondered and and i wanted to pivot to
you know kind of reflections on the
fermi paradox that you you do discuss in
the book it's one of theo's you know he
intuits it sorry robbie the son intuits
it in in a certain sense and i wonder
you know with all these wonderful
discoveries as you've just said
is that making us feel more more alone
more isolated more kind of terrified
because yes at least you could hide in
the background in 1986 and say well you
know we only know of one planet uh where
life could even have liquid water around
a g-type star and you talk a lot about
all these analogs
is it making it worse um this this this
the knowledge that we get is it the
curse of knowledge now we we're even
fermi's paradox is even more crisp than
it was perhaps
even when he asked it the first time
so
it may heighten our anxiety in one sense
but it may also do something very
powerful
and beautiful
for our sense of earthly morality on
another and i'll and i'll get back to
that
in the unlikely event
uh that your viewers don't have a
reference for the fermi paradox i'll
just step it through in a sentence so
you know it references a famous event
back in 1950 uh at los alamos over lunch
when uh
the astronomers of the time were
starting to get a good sense of the age
uh of the universe and the the rate of
uh stellar uh creation which are the
first two terms in drake's famous
equation uh
and the immense the mind-boggling size
of the sample set that we were talking
about was first coming clear to people
and and you know fermi hearing these
numbers stopped over lunch and said
then where is everybody
and that question gets more and more
acute because now we've we have a pretty
strong sense and again please you know
correct this auto didactic novelist at
any turn when you know if i pull out any
numbers that are wrong or any not likely
don't get connected if we're talking
about
on the order
of
hundreds of billions of galaxies
each of which
have on the order of 100 billion stars
and we now know from kepler that those
stars are likely to have at least
you know a handful of planets two or
three planets
that's a big number
and little nine-year-old robin who's
listening to his father
you know whose father says take the
number of grains of sand and multiply
them by the number of trees and that's
how many stars there are out there
you know little robin is saying what
fermi asked and then where is everybody
right
and
your question about whether this makes
our existential loneliness more acute
that we have not either through seti
or through
uh subtler searches by astrobiologists
for
less pronounced uh
forms of life microbial life using
things like
spectroscopy of of you know the light
passing through atmospheres of these
newly discovered exoplanets
we have not yet turned up anything
credible as uh you know another another
fingerprint of life there is some
interesting dispute and i i don't know
where i i think sarah siegel was
involved in this group that was saying
possibly we've overlooked uh bio
signatures on venus in the atmosphere of
v that's right it's kind of mind-blowing
yeah you know when you think of the
conditions there but
one you know one
before before trying to close this
argument about its effect on our earthly
morality
one it does bear pointing out that
astrobiology is not just the search for
life on other worlds it's a broader
field a multi-disciplinary field that's
primarily concerned
with approaching the larger questions of
the relationship between life
and its location
so
uh
abiogenesis the whole question of how
life emerges in the first place what
kinds of chemistry life might be able to
be based on
uh you know all of these questions that
the astrobiologists are searching have
great bearing for life here on this
planet
whatever we you know whatever
biosignatures we may or may not find
out there
we are learning to look at and think
about the resourcefulness the ingenuity
the toughness and the range of life here
in new ways and there's been an
interesting feedback back and forth you
know as we become
really interested in uh
the possibilities of very non-standard
uh habitats uh even looking you know
looking for life on
in places that ordinarily would have not
been included in uh what we would have
considered to be habitable zones a short
while ago rogue planets where there's
you know uh
energy coming from gravitational uh
forces that that you know could could
produce life in the absence of star i
mean that's pretty wild but those those
kinds of of
thought experiment but also rigorous
data gathering back and forth have
retroactively
widened our appreciation for where life
is found here and vice versa you know
discovering extremophiles on earth
in places at temperatures where my
biology teacher in high in college would
have said uh life could not exist
uh has been sobering and humbling and
also exciting because you know just it
throws open all kinds of possibilities i
read just uh yesterday new speculation
about europa moon of jupiter and how how
the ridges
on this uh
crust there's always been suspicion that
there's liquid water underneath this
crust and that though that could be you
know the first place uh off of earth
where we find life not on the planet
itself but on the moon of a planet
um
and and again because of energy from
unexpected sources that you know this
this is looking at those ridges
comparing it to ridges in greenland
and deciding that yes this is a very
exciting indication that there's shallow
salt water
in conditions that are very hospitable
to
the generation of and the sustenance of
microbial life
so it's an amazing project but let's say
you know there there are two
possibilities i mean
uh i'm not sure whether you've had seti
people on oh yeah i've had on jill
tarter and it's that's just nice yeah
the great luminaries of that of course
you know they could
call a press conference tomorrow
it's it is
entirely within the realm of the
possible
and say
yes
this is a non-uh non-random
non-uh geological non-uh physical signal
it's being sent by some biological
entity they could do that tomorrow
now does that make us
better or worse curators of this planet
to to know
that you know one once that k n plus one
has been found then we have this kind of
induction proof of well it's probably
everywhere then um
and
does that make us more cavalier or or uh
you know
more careful about what we're doing to
this planet
the other question is suppose we go on
decade after decade and we can't find
biosignatures anywhere right what does
that do to our sense of where we've
landed and i think actually honestly
in both cases
it should
hugely increase our sense
of how unthinkably lucky the convergence
of
affordances for life
have occurred on this planet
and
you know
to to
to
treat
the one place in the universe that we
know of that is perfect
for the existence and
sustenance of life the way that we've
been treating
has something to do with
the lack of thinking
about just how big it is out there
yeah i i couldn't agree more and in fact
i i feel like it should um i'm kind of a
uh
a little bit of a contrarian when it
comes to life on uh other planets i
actually don't think there is a very
high likelihood of it and i
you know because i'm kind of trying to
be driven by data and
even the most fervent as you say you
know jill tarter and seth rostec um are
would be the most pleased to have
verified the existence of not only life
but extraterrestrial technological
intelligence we'll get to that in a
minute but um but in speaking of you
know as i mentioned before
you know this this ability for science
fiction and again this is extremely hard
it's not even science fiction it's it's
based on actual you know discoveries
data i mean they're they're real people
in this book thinly veiled granite
thundberg makes an appearance donald
trump makes an appearance uh and i love
it uh but um because it's so it's it's
such a fantastic fun read especially for
uh audience members like me who are very
hardcore geeks and dweebs and nerds i'll
just devour it but
you know there's a scene in the movie
contact i mentioned andrew and uh past
guests
and uh there's a scene in the movie
version with jodie foster
who plays jill tarter thinly veiled
reference
and it shows um it shows you know a
press conference with bill clinton on
the white house lawn and that was not
cgi that was an actual event that took
place in 1997 when um when
fossil hunters and meteorite hunters
discovered a what they claimed was the
either byproducts of respiration of a
martian
you know organism or the organism itself
and that richard was a peer-reviewed
paper that was you know nasa doesn't do
press conferences unless it's
peer-reviewed and accepted and published
i believe it was in science and to my
knowledge that discovery has never been
refuted so in other words it has never
been disconfirmed
or confirmed
it arrived in a meteor shower 13 000
years ago
and in 1984
an american scientist on an annual u.s
government mission to search for meteors
on antarctica
picked it up and took it to be studied
appropriately
it was the first rock to be picked up
that year
rock number 84001
today
rock 84001
speaks to us across all those billions
of years and millions of miles
it speaks of the possibility of life
if this discovery is confirmed it will
surely be one of the most stunning
insights into our universe that science
has ever uncovered
its implications are as far-reaching
and awe-inspiring as can be imagined
even as it promises answers to some of
our oldest questions
it poses still others
even more fundamental
we will continue to listen closely to
what it has to say as we continue the
search for answers and for knowledge
that is as old as humanity itself
but essential to our people's future
i think actually the current thinking on
it is that there
uh
may be other possible sources uh
physiochemical sources yes 100 yep and
and that's sort of my metapoint is that
for 20 plus years richard we live with
this ambiguity of whether or not there
was life on another planet and yet the
average person it made no difference
their lives in fact most people don't
even know that that was retracted or not
retracted there was this claim of
extremophiles living in mono lake here
in california also published in science
magazine also uh retracted you know when
it was found it wasn't arsenic life
after all it was in contamination
potentially it's not really clear so
these discoveries to my mind illustrate
exactly what would happen you know a lot
of times i talked with with folks and
they say it would change everything to
know that there's life in the universe
and i think it could
but um but then we have this counter
example that people just went about
their life and they kept polluting the
oceans i mean richard if you or i want
to find life we can just go out into the
ocean you know it's a couple miles away
scoop up a glass of pacific ocean water
and uh they'll be teaming teeming with
organisms uncountable so i mean yet
we're so cavalier as you say about our
stewardship of the planet so i want to
ask you does that depress you i mean it
depresses me
yeah no those are all very good points
um but again i think
i think an ambiguous uh
non-biological
trace
in rocks that
was already being
uh qualified and disputed at the time of
the public announcement is too subtle
for the you know for the public to to
really have their imaginations captured
uh and you know honestly i don't know
when you say you're skeptical about
um
uh
finding other uh
forms of life out there whether that
extends all the way to the microbial but
even unambiguous bio signatures
um
strongly suggesting
microbial existence would be a bit uh
mediated and removed for the public you
know show us the pictures uh tell us
what the you know what the underlying uh
you know uh replication methods are you
know uh tell us that precise chemistry
none of those things are are going to
happen in our lifetime so we're a ways
from those kinds of you know ethical
monumental uh
consciousness changing announcements but
that's where fiction comes in you see
because that you know there's a line in
uh overstory uh it's all
all the best arguments in the world
won't change a person's mind
the only thing that will do that is a
good story yes
and this is what i'm trying to do with
my novels this is what people uh you
know the folks who you mentioned earlier
uh
um
you know uh
from andy weir to kim stanley robinson
are trying to they're trying to excite
the imagination the narrative
imagination of people here on earth
about this
incredible drama that we are a part of
uh
the the movement of the inanimate
universe into something biological is
you know it it is a narrative i will
never be able to wrap my head around
but it's a narrative that you can tell
stories about
and if you create a father who's looking
for things out there if you create a son
who is terrified by what's happening to
the world around him who wants to know
are you serious is half of the large
animal life on earth going to be gone by
the time i'm your age what do you say to
a nine-year-old you know that question i
think can make even a non-scientific
reader stop catch their breath and say
oh my god how would i raise that child
and that yeah maybe this is a good time
to pivot there
i just want to take one quick detour
before i do that uh just to remind folks
talking richard powers uh pulitzer
prize-winning author of the overstory
and most recently 13th novel uh
bewilderment uh which is uh which is
just a delightful book about
astrobiology about
uh what it means to be a uh a father a
son to be a
child in the universe and leave a legacy
um but one one thing uh in the
astrobiological sense you know there was
fred hoyle who was uh the biggest critic
of the big bang theory who really ever
lived uh went to his deathbed he
actually visited san diego many times he
worked with the colleague of mine
jeffrey burbidge and they discovered how
life you know uh could come out uh
perhaps be spread about not origin of
life but but you know spreading of life
called panspermia
which sounds dirty but it's not um and
uh and and one of the other kind of
refutations that i use to bolster my uh
bayesian confidence in the lack of life
elsewhere in the universe is that we
haven't found it on mars and the
argument goes like this that you know
i've got this little chunk of cosmic
space dust here i'll see if i know
i'm going to give it to you when we meet
up someday we have to do
it so this is a meteorite that comes
from a type 2 supernova that blew up in
our galaxy 5 billion years ago and it's
been cruising around and i actually have
a couple of pieces of gram-sized samples
of mars in in my uh laboratory and it's
just for fun i don't do research on it
but uh but this this meteorite sample
from mars has a um a particular uh
characteristic it's matched by the
viking landers and they can prove it's
from mars it landed on earth after being
mars was pummeled by the same meteorites
that hit the earth hit mars travel
around the universe and then hit the
earth and and that's how they think this
this antarctic meteorite landed on earth
so the fact that you know to date we we
don't see any geologic evidence we don't
see any other you know physical evidence
even microbial or tardigrades which you
talk about in the book um you know how
these things could could even exist on
mars although of course we haven't
searched the whole planet and and the
lack of you know evidence is not proof
of lack of existence but um but i wonder
you know is there any you know and this
will be the last topic in in the kind of
uh search for microbial life or at least
in our conversation but is there any you
know peace and i admit what i just said
is not like you know a proof but is
there any evidence that would cause you
to rethink your belief that life is
abundant and and and replete throughout
the cosmos or is that something that
cannot be refuted so to speak
i'm i'm actually agnostic on the matter
if you were to ask me to bet i'd place a
bet on finding microbial life ultimately
once all the tools are in place
um
just simply be because of the uh the the
sample size of possible habitats and
uh you know the
uh
you know if if you roll the dice often
enough you know in a large enough uh
field
um you're gonna you're gonna have
conditions uh close to those here on the
other hand you know there are there are
interesting the the fact that the fact
that life originated so quickly on earth
relative to the origin of the planet you
know as soon as we got out of that
haitian period and things settled down
it was there
but there was there is also something
sobering you know when astrobiologists
look at uh the history of life on this
planet the sobering thing is that the
single cell
if and i think i'm right on the on the
time frame here the latest thinking on
this
went for almost a billion years yeah
that's right before endosomyosis you
know so you know could could it could
earth have never been anything more
than single cell well it was for a good
chunk of its history you know four and a
half billion years
half a billion years or so after you
know after planetary origin we start
seeing
uh uh first life and then nothing for
the next billion years except these very
simple cells
so
that may be
what we see most places you know if we
ever do get signatures it may be that
and whether or not
you know that is a is a is an
existential landmark for us uh remains
to be seen but you know you you've uh
done
uh
great work with galileo you know you
you've recorded audio versions of his
seminal books earth changing books
and remember that the facts that he was
put i mean simply saying
there's something out there that has
bodies rotating around it
all right that was a a nod in our head
and it helped provoke all kinds of
social and political revolutions down
the line so never never underestimate
you know the the
slow catalytic effect
of news from out there
so one of my listeners uh jimmy asks the
question of you uh do you believe that
understanding consciousness is somehow
related to understanding
uh life in the universe in other words
might there be forms of life that we
couldn't recognize
unless we fully understand consciousness
which is i always say richard there are
all these chicken or egg problems you
know which came first you know matter or
or in the universe or energy which came
first you know life or consciousness
um and all these chickens the chicken or
the egg and one of my kids once said i
know how to tell
if you know which came first the chicken
or the egg and i said how how do you do
that
just order a chicken and an egg from
amazon and you say
[Laughter]
here's
an action
so can you tell me uh you've used
unconsciousness is it as you know past
guest deepak chopra said you know the
universe is conscious uh donald hoffman
you know said you know reality sort of
doesn't exist it's all this kind of you
know tableau of of kind of i iconography
that representative uh um you know of of
activity and realism is not correct so
can we understand you know would life
bite us on the rear end and we wouldn't
know it because we are not attuned to
his consciousness
sure yeah i would put it that uh not
only could life do that but it has
throughout a good part of human
intellectual history and i'll i'll
backtrack around uh to make that point
but uh
um
on the chicken and egg
uh i do love the the uh evolutionary
genetics uh uh suggestion that something
not quite the chicken
laid an egg that hatched a chicken
so uh in any case uh this uh this idea
of of all things being in flux uh means
that uh uh you can arrest that equation
at any point and uh decide uh the
precursor um but the
the serious answer to jimmy's question
and i've been thinking about it again uh
having just recently read a really good
book by uh
uh the philosopher and science writer
peter godfrey smith called metazoa
in which he
tries to step through
an evolutionary
view of consciousness
and his point is if you look at
uh
the emergence
of agency in living things primarily
you know the kind of agency that that uh
uh animals and uh fungi uh uh evolve
and if you look at the
uh
evolution of perception
that what you really are looking at are
precursor forms of consciousness
precursor i mean rudimentary
intelligence you know what you know what
what's increasingly called minimal
intelligence um
and that
there may not be a hard problem of
consciousness per se that that that
these
but to look at this as a as a functional
evolution of the
ability to flexibly respond to the
environment
that step by step there you have
consciousness and
that kind of thinking has actually
allowed us
to be a little less blind about the
forms of consciousness
in life all around us
you see in the book theo robin come to
the conclusion that there is alien life
and it's everywhere
and you know we're walking past it all
the time and we're failing to see just
how ingenious and intelligent and
resourceful it is and of course by that
they mean all the creatures of planet
earth
but
again once again not to keep uh
ragging on my professors back in the day
but i distinctly remember sitting in
psychology class and having uh you know
the the instructor say
when your dog jumps all over you barking
and slurping and kissing
it's not happy to see you
right it's just following its instincts
you know that's right
and and now it just seems silly to us
that you know our kind of anthrocentrism
prevented us
with a you know a good faith desire to
keep anthropomorphism out of the
equation prevented us from seeing what
clearly is conscious behavior in other
animals yeah
and of course overstory is a great
uh exploration of the ways in which
minimal intelligence is already present
even in plants yeah in the ways that
they flexibly respond to the environment
and the way they use
uh chemical signaling and uh you know um
resource sharing and
uh network
network dynamics yeah it's it's
unbelievable yeah that is such a
a fascinating um you know and i want to
go now from living organisms to silicon
organisms and ask you in the book
there's uh there's a quite a bit without
giving any anything away i always hated
it when i would come on a podcast and
someone said can you tell us everything
that you read in the book so you know
like so people don't have to buy it yeah
sure of course um but uh but there is uh
the the techniques of um what's called a
decoded neurofeedback
um as a tool using functional magnetic
resonance imaging takes place because as
you've already said you know robin's
mother passes away and and there's a
there's an opportunity for them to kind
of uh connect and that's all i'll say
but it uses this decoded neural feedback
um first i want to ask you about
that do you feel things like elon musk's
you know
neural link project or
that there will be sufficiently brain um
brain
machine interfaces
uh such that someday you know you may
share the pulitzer prize with uh gpt-3
or some you know computing uh
artificially intelligent general
artificial intelligent uh being so
talk about what was what was this um
what does this field like because i
understood you did a lot of research on
this on this new technology
that uh that technique
is an existing
therapeutic modality uh it's been around
since about 2011.
and
the early work was on things like um
pattern formation in in v1 you know the
in the
optical you know visual cortex of the
brain and the the weird ability to uh
train
a
a target brain or a
a
a student brain
on a pre-recorded target
and have a kind of apprehension you know
in in in getting feedback to uh uh train
uh closer and closer to the target
pattern
uh
the student brains were uh
you know producing some uncanny ability
to reproduce the stimuli in the in the
target brains uh it's it's a therapy
that's now you know most of money is
going into exploring its uses for ptsd
and other kinds of uh
you know clinical
uh
trauma uh therapy which is
understandable i mean that's where
that's where the money will be
uh but i i do this uh
uh speculative fiction extrapolation of
that technique and i push it you know
one or two steps into the impossible and
uh produce some uncanny results some
ambiguous results some results that theo
knows can't really be produced by that
uh you know by that procedure but
nevertheless are starting to appear in
his son so i i had great narrative fun
with that and i think it's a it's a it's
a wonderful um
kind of lever to approach this black box
of the brain
and uh to tell
the story of plato's allegory of the
cave again uh in a in a contemporary way
yeah
yeah so do i think do i think that that
uh technologies are going to con
converge that that the ability to do
this kind of very high resolution
uh fmri in real time
the ability to have a
deep learning uh and massive data sets
produce pattern uh recognition and and
uh
extrapolations uh
in an automated way and an odd kind of
brain machine links are they going to
produce
things that right now we would call
impossible no doubt no doubt i mean i'm
64 years old half half of the world that
exists right now would have been
impossible for me to receive up or
credit you know when i was robin's age
that's wonderful
so uh speaking of that well you know
just
i was thinking instead of post-traumatic
stress and i should check richard do you
have another 15 minutes is that oh sure
okay i beg your indulgence on that
please and your forbearance um but
you're so delightful i can't i can't let
uh allow my audience to be denied the
pleasure of hearing these remaining
thoughts from you so
uh you spoke of this in the book as
dealing with ptsd post-traumatic stress
syndrome but i wonder if one of the
themes of the book which is kind of
eco-trauma as you say is almost like pre
i mean nobody very few people are
dealing directly with with the the
effects of you know anthropocentric
genetic climate change you know right
now we don't have billions of refugees
and it means we don't have the scenarios
that are playing out
not yet yeah
but um but it's coming and and so i
wonder could this type of tool be used
as you know pre-traumatic stress
disorder i mean i i can see being used
in in a negative way to placate people
to to
indulge compliance um but i don't know
uh is is is this tool i think it's it's
maybe um part of a greater narrative
that the book evoked in me i i came away
um
as i do i'm a i'm a alien pessimist but
i'm a techno optimist i feel like people
like robbie you know who you know he's
like a young elon musk or something like
that these are the people that change
the world
and i feel like you know with him in in
you know and and in decades or whatever
people like him right um and i'm not
gonna go into the details of the story
but but but i wanna know what what about
the future are you optimistic about i
mean is it existing technology is it
political is it social cultural do you
have a role you know as a writer as well
as someone who's an educated lay person
in science and me as a you know poorly
educated writer but but a good scientist
i mean what are you optimistic about
when it comes to climate change
well
can i start with this question of of of
um
therapy and yes the transformation of
consciousness so you see uh i wanted to
write this book in part
uh
to address
this pandemic
of
the mental health of children that we're
in the middle of
i mean this is a grave
medical crisis
and we're increasingly aware of the size
and the intensity and the magnitude of
this problem
our children are traumatized
and they have a right to be um
and i think the kind of eco trauma that
robin suffers from is not unusual
in children even younger than him all
the way up
to the teenagers who i've been talking
to when i've visited high schools on
this book tour
you know who's who sent despair is
palpable
so
you know the the question is
how do you preserve
hope if you define hope as a meaningful
engagement with the future
a belief that there are things there are
ways of being
that will continue to make the future
meaningful for us right and yes we can
turn to technologies and you mentioned
kim stanley robinson and i think his
ministry of the future recent book is a
is a wonderful exploration of the ways
in which existing human technologies
through improved social institutions
could finally get a handle on these
double catastrophes that we've unleashed
and start to work meaningfully toward
rehabilitating the earth i think those
stories are absolutely essential to tell
when i say we need a transformation in
consciousness
we need a way of thinking that isn't
based on human exceptionalism that isn't
based on
mediating
meaning entirely through acquisition and
through commodities thinking thinking of
meaning as entirely a private thing that
we make by and for ourselves but rather
to recover
older indigenous ways of being on the
earth of seeing interbeing of seeing
kinship with the more than human world
of understanding ourselves as part of an
enormous experiment of the life
principle that ramifies and branches and
manifests itself in all these different
species all these different kinds of
intelligence if we can come back to that
community if we can live here on earth
land back on earth as latour likes to
say you know if we can find kinship in
the more than human
we will be halfway to hope because all
of a sudden now there's an infinite
amount of meaningful work ahead of us
in making planet earth habitable again
and whether or not
you know we can succeed
in
preserving a way of life that's
you know
much like the present is no longer the
issue
i mean
a lot of the way that we live now
cannot
be brought into the future
the numbers don't
work right
and so we're all in shock we're all in
mourning for a way of life that's the
only way of life that we know what we
need
are
kinds of technologies kinds of therapies
kinds of machines
that
can
inculcate that sense
of excitement of awe of kinship of
belonging of community
right and i use one in my book and
you've latched on to it as a possible
interesting technology a literal machine
that can increase our empathy that can
increase our sense of excitement and
tranquility and purpose
but the technology that i'm staking my
claims on
is the other kind of
empathy machine that we call art and
story and and narrative
right
these
the decode decoded neurofeedback and
bewilderment in a way
is a kind of functioning analog
of what we try to do when we say imagine
if you were somebody else
imagine you are this father raising this
boy that itself is a kind of
guided neural feedback into being
someone other than yourself and if we
can find those stories
then we can begin that transformation of
consciousness because we've seen rapid
shift in social consciousness because of
stories that people have told we've seen
the civil rights movement the lgbt
revolution all these other
massive and essential social
transformations that have gone from
very outside uh marginal
uh dark horsey kinds of uh concerns not
penetrating to the mainstream you know
the the the the invested power of
this culture to you know
to basically consensual agreement you
know and and uh acceptance so we know
that that can happen we can and we know
it can happen rather relatively quickly
so
yeah
yeah no i think
there's reason to be optimistic
as well yeah
so um
yeah the last last kind of major subject
i'd like to talk about before we pivot
to the final questions that i love to
ask my guests um it has to do with the
with the craft of being an artist to
being a writer um and i heard a quote
yesterday uh i want to get your reaction
to it one of the things i'm always
obsessed with
is you know can you teach
x can you really teach you know somebody
to be a writer to be a physicist to be
uh to be a poet and and i wonder your uh
reaction to this following um quote from
uh from hunter s thompson who said that
he hand wrote out the great gatsby once
so he could feel for the first time what
it's like to write a great novel
um
when you were a professor how how do you
react to this is it is it possible to
teach the creativity the the the craft
of being a writer or is it only possible
to teach the technique
i love that thompson story you know
because you go to uh
uh
the museum of art
and you see people with their easels
propped up in front of the great masters
and just reproducing that painting and
there's nothing like it you know um
there's a great uh uh porges short story
called pierre bernard the man who wrote
don quixote and what pierre pierre wants
to do is not copy the quixote
he wants to ride it again from scratch
the same way that uh
you know cervantes wrote it uh he wants
to reproduce this book and and i i've
always loved that story it's just been
you know it it's been glorious
inspiration for me there are many many
things you can teach about the craft of
writing there are many many things you
can teach about the spirit and the
nature and the philosophy of writing you
can
train someone to pay attention
and to be present
and you can also
teach them about register and diction
and syntax and scenes and character
creation
whether or not they'll become a great
writer i don't know but they'll become
their best faster
with good instruction for sure
wonderful yes it's uh it's something we
even experimental physicists have to
grapple with uh because like with
children you don't want them to be uh
you don't want them to be just little
carbon copies of you uh and for those of
you out there who are too young to know
what a carbon copy is it's the cc in
your email i mean i don't know how many
people know what cc actually stands for
that's super interesting i haven't
thought about it yeah if you think it's
one of those holdovers from like three
generations of technology um let alone
don't don't even get into blind carbon
copy um well richard it's been uh such a
treat uh talking to you and i want to
just get into these
kind of existential questions if you'll
indulge me with your forbearance for a
few more moments
i want to ask you what i call the
thrilling three
[Music]
so
uh richard the first one of these
questions involves uh what will happen
to you when you reach the biblical age
of 120 years old which is the age that
moses got to be but he didn't get into
the promised land um and we all have our
own promised lands that we don't get
into i suppose uh i want to ask you what
would be your ethical will not your
monetary you know physical will but what
wisdom or values do you cherish so much
that you want to articulate
as an inheritance to generations that
come after you both you know
ideological in other words
and what a great question to meditate on
every day
yes um you know
if if if we could do that for a few
minutes every day yeah the talmud uh the
talmud says write your will the day
before you die but of course you don't
know when you're gonna die so you should
think of it day
now would be a good time yeah
i
think of
aldous huxley's answer to that question
so huxley you know one of the great you
know
uh
progenitors of the of speculative
fiction yeah he said you know he said i
i'll get the quote slightly mangled but
it was something like um
it's embarrassing to have spent an
entire lifetime
studying the human condition and to have
nothing more insightful to say than
pay attention and try to be a little
kinder
but that's a big that's a big too if you
can do them both together i mean no
notice the way that they would play off
each other and but the the real question
is how do you continue to pay attention
and how do you continue to to try to be
a little kinder despite all the
the the habits that we fall back into
you know with all our best intentions
and i you know the the the hinge on that
i think would be
uh you know another quote would be the
william goldman quote you have to
remember that nobody knows anything
about anything
and that that degree of of skepticism
and uncertainty
should be pointed inwards
and produce a kind of standing condition
of humility whatever you think
you're sure of right now is probably
wrong
in some ways and uh you know if you can
hold that in mind
then of course it gets easier to say
well then pay attention and try to be a
little kinder because that's all we have
you know we're all in this vulnerable
state of contingent knowledge
very good beautiful link um so the next
uh question uh has to do with the famous
scene from 2001 a space odyssey where
are these
monoliths these structures we don't
really know what they are um they're
perhaps built as a time capsule a
warning some sort of
braggadocio from an extraterrestrial
species
and uh they're we're not really clear
what they're supposed to be but now
we're gonna go from 120 years in the
future to a billion years in the future
right and i should say i asked andrew in
this and she said oh i i did this i i
recorded my brain waves and carl put it
on a pioneer 10 golden plaque
right
right
the question makes me think of the
things that they that they put on on
these uh
uh probes that were going leaving the
solar system that's right yeah exactly
she actually created eco music i think
what's called you know or earth music or
something like that there was no concept
of world music back then and they
sampled all these different you know
cultures and their musicals you know and
different kind
but i wanted to ask
whale song on it too yeah yeah her brain
waves and it was just after she had
fallen in love she said with carl and it
was really quite beautiful but i want to
ask you you know with that massive build
up you know don't be intimidated um but
what would you put on as sort of a
a way to maybe for us to brag about what
we've accomplished as a species or what
what kind of um
you know
basically advertisement for the earth
and for the human species which as we
already said is the only at least known
species of life that exist
of technological and and uh conscious
behavior that we are familiar with what
would you put on a monolith destined to
last for a billion years
well it's super interesting and you know
not unrelated to the kind of corollary
question that a filmmaker contact asks
okay we've got him on the line
now what do we say to him you know and
louis thomas actually wrote a great
essay on this you know the the physician
uh medical researcher and an sas who
wrote you know uh columns for nature i
think years years and years and and were
collected in great collections like the
lives of a cell he wrote on seti and
he's saying
okay so now we've said hello
it's going to take 200 years to reach
them
and then it's going to take 200 years
for the high how are you to come back
from them you know and civilizations are
rising and falling
you know can you hear me can you hear me
and now and now we have to you know we
have to do that bragging here's who we
are you know here's what we know
and
thomas says you know the first the first
temptation is is to is to put something
you know like uh f equals m a or you
know some some really foundational uh
uh
physics or chemistry insight you know
and then he says now you know if they're
reading this and decoding it they
already know that right so uh you know
let's try something and you know that
there's there would be a temptation to
say well you know here's the double
helix and here's how it works and then
again you say well you know that's
either going you know it's not likely to
be directly interesting to them it's
going to seem like a little parochial
thing like okay we'll put that in a
footnote in our in our
own economy of other right
and it he comes up thomas comes up with
a great answer he says i would vote for
the music of bach uh streamed outwards
into outer space continuously all of
bach you know he says
we would be lying of course about who we
are
but there would be plenty of truths of
the time for the harder truths later on
i've always loved that
all right so so richard power's answer
is a cd-rom with bach on it yeah
hopefully they'll be able to play the cd
i i would actually my answer you know
when i think well what's the
what is the what keeps coming up in all
different human disciplines what do we
keep discovering again and again and
again as a foundational truth
and the closest thing that i know to
that in disciplines all the way from
cosmology to to theater
is
you know the the summation for it would
be for me that you know the the the
little uh sound bite of after north
whitehead saying there is no independent
mode of existence
everything is what it is by virtue of
everything else
right and this desire this this this
search for an independent mode of
existence
truths that are true everywhere and for
all time
is a kind of limited endeavor and
you you in order to go much farther than
that you have to
to really start to
you know absorb this idea of
interdependence
yeah i i like that very much
very good okay richard the final
question we've we've looked into the
crystal ball we've we've looked out in
the universe in the future what it will
behave like but now we're going to go
back in the past we're going to use a
telescope
with galileo called a perspective tube
to reveal what wisdom you might give to
your former self and i call this
question the into the impossible
question because it's one of arthur's uh
famous laws the third law says the only
way of discovering the limits of the
past impossible of the sorry the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible and that's the
origin
of the name of the podcast so i ask you
what mysterious aspect of life may have
perplexed you as a 20 year old or 30
year old um that with the clarity of and
wisdom of age and and and
and life events that you've experienced
would give you the courage to go as
you've gone into the impossible and
it shouldn't not only be the the fact
that you were going to be a physics
major and yet you didn't decide i'm
disappointed personally
but there's always time i've got some
non-traditional students coming back so
maybe maybe one day but what would you
tell yourself yeah well gosh yeah and i
i do i do love that clark quote and i
you know i should tell my little arthur
clark story which is
in uh
in 1997 i was part of uh
of a conference at the university of
illinois
celebrating uh the birth of hal
wow and
as he
gave it a birthdate in his novel yeah
that's right and and in the in the novel
he says you know uh when when uh hal is
being disassembled and he's regressing
to childhood he's saying i'm a hell 9000
robot i was born in urbana illinois in
1997. so we in urbana decided we were
going to have a birthday party for him
and we had to get arthur clark to that
birthday but by that time he wasn't
leaving sri lanka and we had one of the
very very first
tele live
telepresence uh
with clark in sri lanka and it was
spotty it was dropping out but there he
was
on this enormous screen in an auditorium
in urbana talking to us and answering
our questions in real time that's
impossible
well here we are brian the technology
has been smoothed out a little bit in
the end
but there's a message there right and
you know it has to do it in a little bit
with my first answer and a little bit
with my second answer but but ultimately
it has to do
with calming the anxieties of the young
richard by saying look your equation is
missing a delta t
right do not be too anxious about your
current state what you know what you
don't know what you know do not pursue
too vigorously the eternal verities
because
everything that you know
everything that you can know
and everything that is available to to
be known out there
all of those are works in progress
that's my message to to my younger self
let it unfold
wow that is very delightful and it
involves the most mysterious aspect of
life which is time we don't understand
it and yet it emerges and we all
experience it but richard i want to
thank you for spending so much of your
valuable time with me i hope we can meet
in person i've uh a a stockpile of gifts
that i'd love to give you for all the
gifts you've given me with your
wonderful writing
and uh and i wish you a remaining lovely
time in our fair state until you return
to the great smoky mountains it sounds
so romantic so beautiful
richard
richard powers author of many books 13
books including this which is uh
actually in addition to oprah one of the
many things we have in common uh it's
one of my favorite books uh and and you
simply must uh
give yourself the gift out there
listening to it and and reading it is
such a delight richard thank you so much
i i really appreciate it so i'm so
grateful it was a great pleasure for me
brian thanks for having me on
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you